this week we've got hidden tortoise
Batman surprise and let's break up what
was that part of the weekend scramble or
is that just you saying it to him I'm
just announcing our breakup that would
be good okay great and I want a divorce
that would be really good like what kind
of sick how my my own and I did cheat
your car yeah right
all right so for our first story there's
this British woman who was in Spain who
went to the hospital because she was
suffering pain in her genital area which
then no doctors found a dead reptile
what what did she put up there harness
they are calling it a tortoise but then
other reports are calling it a turtle so
I don't know what one of the two wait no
full turtle swim so in his Sheldon there
[ __ ] a fish but I don't think he can
get out of their shell no it's a front
he was in the shelf yeah a turtle yeah
they kind of sea turtle in that you know
you should always wash your hands after
touching a ready or slider because I
heard that you get like skin diseases
and stuff from them yeah but I didn't
hear that if you touch your [ __ ] after
a girl's up inside it it was dead and
there's an infection and [ __ ] do you
think she didn't know that's the thing
she says she doesn't know how a [ __ ]
turtle went up her because you like
listen I got [ __ ] up last night no
idea what happened what's up cuz you
know Turtles don't try to go through
[ __ ] I know the natural habits
Turtles job - are you a scientist we
obey - Oh big a turtle is okay okay baby
turtles that are like like this small
baby was trying to get to the ocean
looking for a salty place to know when
if it was a actual big-ass turtle it was
just a turtle head in her [ __ ] and she
was just hanging holding that
[ __ ] all day this person I don't
know this is this story is so big tell
me that much but yeah that's a that's a
Spanish turtle yeah Christine but she's
English she was like it's the risk they
take too [ __ ] salty yeah but it's
just like a big ass so what she has a
turtle infection now Cascione infection
because what they even call it though
staph infection or is it you didn't tell
me it just says infection special turtle
associated yeah I guess because of the
fact that it's like dirty and like it's
a reptile can you imagine having a
reptile in your vagina [ __ ] no how did
the turtle not start chomping inside
well they just always bite and nibbling
[ __ ] yeah it was a really nice turtle or
maybe it was already dead
I feel like there's a very key story
bathing yeah I feel like there's a guy
missing that was inserting this turtle
up in in and a [ __ ] and then like she
was embarrassed to tell I think or she's
freaking about it like people put
hamsters up you're like oh yeah people
really do that they really do that
hamsters out there but what is that I
thought I would like that Richard great
yeah Richard Gere rubra ever and I could
never know I never know he was the the
main subject of that rumor but obviously
like there he came out saying like what
the [ __ ] I don't even know where this
came from like that's not true I never
put a hamster I heard it was George
Clooney
yeah I heard George Clooney - one of the
most common and that's how you start a
rumor I don't hear though I really did
that's funny one of the most common
things in the ER room though is [ __ ]
stuck in the [ __ ] yeah I used to work
at hospitals and there used to tell me
all the time like the surgical techs it
would be like you know oh my god it's so
funny we just pull this [ __ ] shampoo
bottle and he's been here like three
times in a month I love the idea that
the doctors have to keep a straight face
so like well obviously the object is in
the posterior area no actual tire my
Frodo ISM but then you guys privately
you're all like this guy had a shampoo
bottle of this and guess what it's the
Costco version know the vo 5 ingredients
third time that guy's been there to like
come back no this other one - or this
man he went into the ER with his wife
and his daughter because like they were
like the wife was playing freaky and it
was like a glass dildo oh I heard of a
lightbulb one time yeah there's been
like a light bulb a light bulb
isn't that more expensive than a [ __ ]
dildo am I crazy no a light bulbs a
dollar yeah man if it breaks and the
that's the game not that new halogen
maybe it was one of those like the loo
because we're in the dildo I'm picturing
like a three-year light bulb that [ __ ]
in yeah you know I mean I thought they
were just trying to produce electricity
through their bodies I thought it's a
little brighter crazy there's so many
stories that I come across with people
like men that have [ __ ] stuck up their
ass to please show you the x-ray in it's
like the hole all their torso taken up
by that thing yeah whatever one turtle
in your [ __ ] that's gross
if she were to choose something I would
think it would be something less turtles
aren't sexy is what you're saying go
ahead and says yeah I am saying it not
sexy well no and they seem sharp big
just being a little sharp reptiles just
don't think that well what I'd like a
little salamander they see my gruesome
turtles have all that texture you know
like when you have those veins and those
like wrinkles there's there's a
softshell turtle - yeah it is if I was a
hardshell ourselves special ones are
what the Asian people what color turtle
is in her [ __ ]
these are the questions we should be
asking the color brown or green yes she
probably took a fish up in there first
and then the turtle was trying to get
chased after that there's a there's
gonna be a bird a pelican and her [ __ ]
after that it's gonna be yeah oh maybe
she put an egg up there not knowing what
kind of
that's pretty good alright moving on to
the next story have you guys heard that
Batman's penis was shown for the first
time ever I heard about that
it's in a comic or whatever I think that
people were pissed off about it I'm like
of course Batman has a dick yeah but
like kids read that not anymore not
anymore no so this is part of this
brand-new DC Comics thing where they're
making it for like a more mature
audience than fiction
basically just like an edgier Batman you
know in the Fox a Batman The Dark Knight
came out it was like oh he's like
[ __ ] darker and edgier dude
Batman is all about striking fear in the
heart of criminals and I don't know what
the Batman just witnessed is
intimidation yeah nothing boys do the
only thing scarier for criminals than
police is a man that's about to rape you
see the issue is part of DC's black
label and they're saying that this will
be quote classy collectible superhero
stories aimed at mature readers looking
to be challenged and surprised as
they're entertained but this dick is
surprising yeah but this whole like as a
black dick because he's a dark ball they
have the Japanese Batman now right he's
a ninja Batman
have you seen that oh no and it made it
thing yeah I don't know what that I
think it's like a companies but yeah
they did an anime Batman yeah yeah the
separate component the dick one yeah you
have to like look really close because
really hard all right start this is the
uncensored version so if you guys can
see right that's his day that's it
crazy man circumciser away we want a
well lit dick you know what I was hoping
I was hoping she would stand over a
criminal anything would be in the mirror
and you can see the report flash from
its camera and you see a sending DC they
ended up releasing a censored version
cuz they're like well this doesn't
really add to the story and oh yeah so
no just like that
I mean that's literally just like one
stroke just like took out is he's
standing in front of a Batmobile looks
like it yeah he's jacking off in a
Batman he's beating off
I can't imagine Ben Affleck doing that
being like that that's really good he's
like really what it's [ __ ] Batman
super but like that is like we're like a
freakin Wolverine this is more like Hugh
Jackman Lucy the arms to dude he was cut
his all [ __ ] am I crazy he was cut Andy
who's nude in the shower in the Batman
Superman movie and I can show you
exactly when and where in the film
there's a shower scene where you can see
his buttocks
no that's Chris Pratt no it's not it's
Ben Affleck you can see his [ __ ] ass
it's a completely sever move what's the
controversy on how you just remember
that so I'll never forget it but you
need to because I was like there's the
Batman that's finally he always teased
you right and Batman Forever they showed
the but real quick but then it was like
behind the latex or whatever but now
they finally showed for the first time
they actually showed the Batman I don't
even think it was a real Affleck asked
though
it was it was a flex s and I was very
proud I was like finally the character
like he gets to show his but finally the
progression of the story
this is what I've paid my $15 for what's
the controversy over like are people mad
because they're like I don't want to see
a dick I want to see some titties well
from what I read like I didn't come
across people being angry I just saw
that people are like oh it's been zero
days since I've seen Batman's junk or
Batman's obsession these are tweets
Batman's obsession with expensive cars
makes so much more sense now that I've
seen what he's working with or oh
they're sayings dick small I mean that
one the thing is is that the fans never
care or the the internet never cares
it's always mom's and the media that
cares but they're dumb ones if they're
letting their kid read the black DC's
black label cause it's not meant for
kids yeah but a dick is like a dick now
go get it dick is a dick I've seen so
many know but it's like whatever what's
but when you're a kid you've seen your
own dick am I crazy
would you haven't seen the Batman tip I
want to like give my kid play some
[ __ ] dick boobs but if I see titties
all over the place like I'm like oh
that's darling that's a bit much you
were complaining about titties at the
strip club you're like oh my god oh yeah
get desensitized all the TV I wonder
what the thought process was behind the
writers to make this decision it's like
you know what we need to do something
edgy how about boobs now boobs are
overrated
yeah dick that's the reason why they're
censoring it because they're saying that
it wasn't additive to the story so
that's why they and when are with
titties ever adding to the story exactly
what other people were saying - they're
like oh that's not added to a story then
Wow I'll tell you one time they're
included that's what they're saying now
like unless it's a specific sex scene
then they're not gonna be having new Oh
what they ruin it for everybody cuz they
showed up instead no it just means
there's gonna be a lot of bad men sex
scenes
no there's not they're not gonna turn it
to Batman hentai yeah what if what if it
was purposely for kids going through
puberty and the parents didn't oughta
talk about the bees and the birds and
[ __ ] and nah be dope having Batman that
was like your body's changing you're
getting pretty mad about it sometimes
you crash the Batmobile and your clothes
burn off and you got to be naked
Christian Bale for that one I just
notice how many blowing things he has on
this table
oh you're late he's always there all
blowing stuff dude like look what are
you trying to say in is that some kind
of gay thing is over shame I mean like
I'm kind of jealous oh I see you're on
the same table you guys are like really
close I mean I just said no you like to
be low there is this Scottish comedian
who he is now pretty much very proud of
the fact that he has broken up 4,000
relationships and caused 17 divorces in
just 10 days
4,000 when he released an email list of
something no so kids you Patrick
yeah I behold record name is Daniel
sloths and he has his new Netflix series
of like multiple shows like his stand-up
shows and then in this one episode
called jigsaw there's this 20 minute
joke there that really like makes
couples realize that holy [ __ ] I'm not
with the right person and all these
people are breaking up and they're
tweeting at him they're sending him
Instagram DM saying like okay
congratulations you can add another
account to your account because I just
broke up with my wife of 13 years oh my
god Wow let's hear this joke let's hear
what
what is it what is it no I'm gonna play
a little clip of his interview on a TV
show hurry up it's it's not a breakup
show I've always said jig so it's just a
love letter to single people like I I
think as a society we pressure people to
get into relationships and I think
there's a certain level of arrogance to
people in relationships that they have
on social media of like me and this one
going for coffee like this I feel like
they're rubbing it in the faces of the
people that aren't in relationships when
deep down they're equally unhappy and I
don't like the smartness of it and I'm
the smartest person I know so why
lifesmart them and now they're getting
divorced okay so you're basically saying
that you don't think they're as happy as
they say they are is that right I think
some people are in love and I the I
can't break those relationships and I
would never want to yeah all I'm doing
is asking you the uncomfortable
questions that you don't have the
courage to ask yourself and I bet my my
own money on it that you won't last
Wow not proud of this you know I
actually watched this last night his 20
minute joke that he's talking about and
what is inking like you know it's not
that late it's not too late to leave in
two years so what what is it exactly
that he's saying that makes people like
question their relationship I'm saying
like the whole jigsaw analogy like I
want a butcher you guys should watch it
for yourselves but he's pretty much
saying that when he was a kid I his dad
gave him this jigsaw analogy saying that
like cuz he asked him like what's the
meaning of life and then the dad was
trying to come up with an explanation
for him when he's seven so he was like
alright well everyone is working towards
creating a jigsaw puzzle we all start at
the corners which is like your family
your work your hobbies whatever and then
like you're all working towards the
middle and then he's like well what what
what are we all working towards and so
the dad answered for your soul mate like
that last piece that just completes your
jigsaw puzzle like your whole life but
then he ends up saying like well I so
pretty much what you're saying is if you
don't have that one last missing piece
here jigsaw puzzle then you're
incomplete and that's like a wrong
message to give to the world like if
you're not gonna be a complete person
without your soul mate and my
really dive dives deep in it he's really
funny in my opinion so he he just really
explains this in a 20 minute joke and
how like you're not in complete if you
don't find someone and the reason why a
lot of us are with other people is
because we're so programmed into
thinking that we need to have someone in
our life so we just we Jam that piece in
there even though it doesn't really fit
so that's kind of like his whole thing
and I didn't get to watch it with Casey
because he was busy working but I really
want to watch it with him and do
anything I agree with a lot of ya cuz
that's why I like a lot of people in
their 30s like well I'm with this person
yeah.well it's because well I like a lot
for most of the country their pressure
to get married like really early there's
social pressure from family I feel like
it's almost the opposite like if you're
married it's like oh that's too much
that's weird you're aware but in other
places in the country it's like if
you're oh you're 26 and you're not
married with three kids already like
what the [ __ ] you doing and so they just
like settle down with the first person
that seems like they might click and
then they are like oh [ __ ] what am i
doing like like oh I know I'll have a
kid yeah and we'll get closer because
we're raising the kid [ __ ] this didn't
work let's have two kids me about the
closeness either if he was also saying
how like each each of us are told that
we have like to create our own jigsaw
puzzle and that person needs to fit me
in ours and so like you're forcing the
other person to change to fit into yours
or vice for you they're changing you to
fit into theirs it would shouldn't it
should complete both of your jigsaw
puzzles i both of us were actually
prepared to be single for a long time
after our previous relationships we did
not expect to get together that's the
best when you don't expect yeah because
when you're looking for it then you're
so desperate to find that that's true
and I was so happy alone and I was like
the next person better just make it
better you know like it couldn't they
can only make it better and like anyone
I dated that wasn't really making it
better no dude I came out of a four-year
relationship and I was with Nikki two
weeks later it's like that and then I
got married it's like that there's Chad
but I was ready I was ready to be alone
I ain't give a [ __ ] I was like
same spot because after like before
Casey I was engaged I was with three
years at that dude I'm like one month
later that's when I mean he's started
eating and I was like wait but I wanted
knows your selfies how'd it go 28 days a
[ __ ] she was my biggest [ __ ] I know I
think a lot of people too it's like you
know I see this a lot where it's like
they're never at fault and and it's it's
just everyone's always blaming you know
the other person and they're not
mentally strong enough to work through
the problems oh you know it's something
like you said that really next record
was Daniel she was saying that a lot of
the people like statistically almost
everyone that is in a relationship
they're forcing it with is because they
are not happy with themselves so they
employ someone else to do that job yeah
you can't find happiness externally yeah
you have to be happy with yourself
definitely and I think we have the
opposite here in LA where it's like we
have so many options yeah so it's like
people aren't settling down like because
as soon as there's something that goes
wrong in a relationship they'll go [ __ ]
it someone else there's gonna be someone
else better that can fulfill my g thing
is cool do that there's 7.5 billion
people on this planet you'll find
someone else
that's what do you think you know what's
probably gonna happen though the
probably the problems usually with the
person that goes from partner to partner
- partner to partner and they can't ever
settle down because they don't find they
don't fix themselves yeah they go oh now
no I have a we have a problem so I'm
just gonna move on to someone else that
could probably fulfill my happiness I'm
not finding the right one which is the
same problem that you have in a very
long-term relationship where you're not
in love with somebody
exact same / it's the same just in
different circumstances yeah yeah just
recast the role because the people
aren't willing to work on themselves
that's actually a psychological thing
with with everything every relationship
in your life if you look back at in high
school all of your same issues you just
recast those same people over and over
again until you fix that issue and then
you stop having those toxic
relationships
and maybe the way life works is that we
do several lives until we figure it out
I think Hey real bad name I think I'm a
little bit Buddhist Metis uprightly love
revenge so much that hey so maybe I got
to work that one out and stamp it out
next time or maybe the next three lives
because I really love revenge I think
I'm here to help you I think you are too
but yeah you I always kill his revenge
movie does she's always like I go after
this person like this I'm like Nam
hey take it down Oh why she's always
like I'm cute why my [ __ ] but it works
so people that raging fire of my heart
though but I'm like today I'm so cute
like want to do that Daniel the whole
thing at the end though he was saying
like what his dad was trying to say it
was not that a partner is the last piece
of your project puzzle it's not you
whatever the puzzle no it's like
whatever makes you big [ __ ] huh Mikey
good for you
no I'm saying what he's saying is that
what he thinks his dad was trying to say
is that whatever makes you happy every
single day that makes you truly happy
that's the last piece of your puzzle so
for him for his dad was his mom so then
that's why he kind of said that I was
you're like so for his dad it was
alcohol yeah I think the pursuit of
constant happiness is actually what
makes people sad because in life there's
gonna be downs like death is a part of
life loss is a part of life sickness is
a part of life like all these things
that go down like you're not supposed to
be happy during those times and you're
supposed to ride out the waves but
that's what makes happiness awesome is
that you you kind of get a reality check
you hit the lows you hit through the
drop you go through that but then when
you come back up you're like oh she
appreciate it more cuz you know what the
other it's like a movie right like if
you don't have like the downfall and
everything just works out perfectly good
movie you guys want to know the meaning
of life I'll give it to you right now
the meaning of life you can find no [ __ ]
that
that's old Steve that's that's I don't
like that what's the meaning of my
meaning of life
you can have you you have every time
that you go to an arcade okay you walk
into the arcade it's super really like
whoa this is amazing look at the lights
look at the [ __ ] all the games and
[ __ ] okay cool and then you go you only
get a certain amount of quarters to play
a certain amount of games and the games
are fun while you're playing them and
then afterward you traded your tickets
for some shitty things that can't make
you happy in the end those are all the
other things that you buy in life right
so you're saying the games are what's
fun not that not that things that you
get yes yes sir not the possessions that
you get the moments that you get what
the plane ride needs to be fun you need
to watch all the movies not be I
actually love plane rides I like the
business class plane ride say not not
one I'm in coach most of the time the
meaning of life is a business class
plane ride you get on the plane you look
at all the plebs walk by you're like get
out of the [ __ ] aisle and go to coach
right way to them yeah you harass the
stewardesses and all then the steward
and then you get free order you you get
free [ __ ] if you're rich enough and
everyone else in the back gets to hear
the engines and suck the fumes see you
in hell but would it be as good if there
were no economy seats no one no because
everything will be the same and then
you'll start complaining about how it's
so straight and that's the socialism
what's first-class service if everyone's
getting it yep it's the same class
service and [ __ ] that so life is not
good unless you get to stomp on others I
want to be special and if special means
someone's at the bottom of my shoe then
stop stop
[Music]